[Music]
I'm a header booking service AI Division
and I had at the same time head of a
technical strategy division and then
mobile yes and I frankly this is a
little bit Estes for me because you know
flick me or not I'm up one of a popular
speaker in Korea and I believe I do a
very good speech in Korean but I have to
speak in English now very nervous and I
frankly try to cancel this session
several time because you know I just use
this event to push my developer to
develop on time my product and company
product and I said yeah I have to do a
some speech in USA so you have to beat
the schedule and I just have forgot to
cancel it a little bit earlier last week
I tried that call to head over a pair at
Google cloud and I said I'm not happy
and I want to cancel this project and I
want to cancel this event and that they
said why and and the yield name already
printed out everywhere and that you had
to do that and I said oh no no no no no
my my presentation is not so popular
there isn't nobody want to attend there
but so many guys here yeah thank you for
showing this event and yes so I spend
maybe three days three hold my days to
prepare the material to share my
experience of GCP and also my pleasant
memory with Google PSO so
but people do that I just want to
introduce the marble to you do you
familiar to me model maybe a demo is a
very big game company but in Korea
number one but in USA I think everybody
just know Kabam or gem city that is our
branch we acquire their companies but
the mobile is not so popular so I really
want to introduce the mobile then I will
explain what kind of a thing we are
doing for AI and the machine learning
then I just want to share what we did
and some did draw a deep dive some cases
34 maybe a 3 3 case I prepared yes this
is in the mobile is our logo and this is
our main characters the name is cookie
is something like mimic the voice when
you are smiling and believe it or not
this is dinosaur we our chairman Sir
that is dinosaur but yeah looks like a
little bit crocodile but anyway that is
title sir your localize our silver color
and this is show our key titles from a
marble transformer and the linear to and
stone age m and seven nights and
everybody's mobile this is our key
titles our paper still nervous okay yeah
we are using our external IP to our
Lydia's marketing cost so why we are
lower marble from Disney and maybe a
transformer from a hospital and at the
same time we try to make our own strong
IP
I was through the seven night the center
this was our original IP and we bought
Stone Age and this is a modern mobile
everybody's mobile and that there is
also our original IP and this one is a
lineage to one of our very popular IP
MMORPG IP and the we borrowed that from
NCsoft and the we are make a huge
success in Korea and that baby I don't
know everybody see that TV CF we using a
Conan O'Brien for marketing this title
in USA but we expecting a huge success
in USA but not so much we just tried but
failed anyway it's a still we try our
best to make a more bigger success in
USA this is our history the mobile is
not young company we are the mobile was
founded in 2000 and we are doing a piece
she boba artist game developer and also
a publisher and that we changed the
whole direction from in a 2013 from a PC
to mobile and that we succeed that and
we are continuously growing off so test
we have a partnership with a ten-cent
and ng soft and we acquired the gem city
and we acquired a car bomb and we we
going to bigger and bigger with the
innovation for example this title name
is cha cha cha is everybody's this is a
the first casual game mega-hit game in
Korea and this is a monster taming and
the we Baker standard over mobile RPG in
Korea and also
we try the real-time barrel with a booth
we're mobile everybody's mobile and that
this is a phenomenal is a big huge
success in this period our marketing
share our market share in Korea is over
50% is crazy
and and then we launched linear tool
evolution if we expect more hardcore
title will be a popular in a mobile
scene so we launched MMORPG and that it
also made a huge success and we acquired
a car bomb the in the gem city to crack
in the the USA market you know we are
Korean so it's really hard to understand
what wisdom guys love so we just find or
solve a simple solution using money I
know
okay so company yeah yes
this is our lab in your growing crap you
know it's crazy right
and we maintained if this slope
continuously as this day - and now we
lasting here we are number three
publisher combining our f toe and Google
and the only for Google we are number
one as far as I know if hope you're
right yeah this is numbers we are very
proud of that and we are the most free
game publisher globally and the levy
news CH ER is 89% and a 68 million Mau
is a bigger than Korea total population
and we have independent and 19
independent development studios and yes
we have at least over 3,000 developers
in Korea maybe a we are over 3500 right
foot soldier he is growing up very fast
and the funny thing is we just have a
only 4% global market share on board
said we expecting maybe a grow more
pester maybe five or six and ten and my
my chairman overage pushing us to get a
more market share globally and then they
Marvel ranked in global market very high
place all over the world and the China
we didn't have any vision yet because
you know Korea in the China government
has over political issue and that is
really hard to enter China market but I
think we can enter China market maybe I
fear we expecting that and that will
make a more bigger cross this year
and creates a still number one market
for us but number three is a North
America and that number three is a Japan
and re focusing on a open market this
year to be a double one in Japan so
yesterday we launched a new title king
of fighter ulster yesterday and it looks
like a very good start
yes this is a our studios chart and I I
want to show you this because we have so
many studios that means that we have a
federal five flying to development many
flagship title and that makes us doing
business very aggressively for example
last week we launched stone-age m and
this week we launched chemo fighter
hasta next month we will launch a new
title Maivia in korea next next month
also we're launching new title somewhere
we aggressively searched thank you so
what are we doing with the artificial
intelligent and watching learning so I
just want to explain their mobiles
uniqueness we are leading a mobile game
published from PC to mobile and we still
have a small PC business and yeah going
to mobile and at the same time we are
not focusing on a one channel we doing a
sum of a casual game and at the same
time we develop still develop our action
RPG and these day are reactive we
developing an MMORPG for making more
bigger money but still we we are
searching our new gem Lord you chance to
to
grow up more pester I think there is a
big difference between us and the other
mobile game company usually general
company just the focusing on a one
gentleman or one title but we do various
jamming for various target from a casual
user to a hardcore and from a simple
game simple project game - MMORPG we
develop every kind of title and we were
the hit for many countries in the for
the world seven knights militia fight
limited to chemo fighter Ulster we are
making a huge success in Korea Southeast
Asia and Japan and also United States we
expecting more bigger to do that we do
many thing you know especially we are
making various attempt to enact a mobile
game operation in a marketing in Korea
we define what is mobile best mobile
game best marketing that means that we
use all kind of a media channel
including TV and ultra and billboard for
two weeks
we spend crazy money only for tweets and
that make us our branding then hugely
success that is a simple formula in
Korea for making a huge money in a in
Vida mobile title we are defined there
and also at the same time we are test or
the October global marketing trend for
exam for performance marketing in Korea
you know Pokemon marketing is not so
important as I said mass marketing
dominated you know the the tamaki
mobile game market so general Korean
companies virgin too familiar to
performance marketing in here
performance marketing is a major and the
may be a TV commercial or people is not
major right
I don't know looks like but in Korea we
collecting all kind of information about
the best marketing and the outside of
Korea we are adopting a performance
marketing trend and also in Japan
Japanese a very very unique place that
is very very hard to understand why this
kind of method is working and why this
is are not working it's really really
hard to understand but we try to make
success in Japan several during us our
years and are we collecting all kind of
information and of it finally we are
obtained you know currently uh now we
believe we are almost has a same ability
as you know checking company
so the mobile strengths for AI and
machine learning will be various my
various best data in the operation
though how we have various attack madera
various market various marketing message
the various operation schedule to
hardcore from Asia to Europe and North
America performs marketing based on a
mascara and the pestle station to a
Japan marketing speciality and
maintaining flagship title for inside of
top 10 loving a chart over 5 years we
collecting their kind of data for 5
years
that is our special weapon and that we
believe that is a key difference and
between memo and other game company but
you know the kind of data is important I
think that is important because you know
also title usually enjoying messages are
just the one thing right compare and the
siddur ending mobile game is a quite
different is based on is a free-to-play
to maximize your exposure at the same
time we prefer all kind of a contents to
maintain retention rate - generate
somebody really love competition
somebody really love community somebody
really love challenging somebody really
love power so we we prepare every kind
of content in a one title to maximize
our success possibility there is the
Mobile's way so you know this blue shape
is a Korea and the disease Brazil and
this is time USA Taiwan same title same
one build but every country enjoy that
different way it's really really funny
and this is a time axis and that this is
a number but I enjoy the content it you
know blue one is Korea and Papa one is
us a huge difference you know the
easiest way to conquer or be a number
one it's some title there are theories
that you know you know some most
efficient way if you just but anyway
music I flow differently Korea might
play differently everybody differently
we have the kind of a dip in game data
I believe it's Lily Lily Lily powerful
weapon for us but problem is we have a
huge legacy over publishing business
from PC side so that is why we have a
very good relationship with the Google
cloud and that we hope to change our
legacy to our cloud trend as soon as
possible and then we need a huge help
maybe Cooper PS so because of the rapid
transition from a pitch to mobile there
are so many legacy on this game side and
the games of architecture is not
suitable for mobile cloud and also our
analytics is a nice suitable for mobile
and are we changing everything as soon
as possible and I think we can if we can
change our platform to a public cloud
like Google crotchety
and if we can combine everything with
the data we have I think we can be a
very strong AI emotion learning company
maybe can be so my mom launched a knock
earlier this year to develop new
business new AI business with this data
and our operation know how I know knock
means a little bit drop the latest thing
in here but I said I don't use this name
but anyway my chairman decided to use
this one
knock means the mobile AI revolution
center and the revolution is our keyword
- for marketing and we hire joonyoung be
17 years he works at an IBM PJ wasn't
Lee such a center and he has a maybe a
father over maybe one of the fathers
over Watson and everybody Haiti wasn't
anyway yeah
Joon young me is currently at the head
over knock and at the same time CTO over
the mobile he are leading every change a
technical side yeah I was R&D strategy
is very simple we have to make AI based
game development leader using our AI
technique and we want to make more
better operation with AI solutions yes
you know this charter said we can do
everything we will do everything but
yeah we already make us over some
progress said Lee postman running
everybody try that but we try leap was
learning to serve our balancing problems
and also we are making a game simulator
to
you say AI technique and at the same
time we doing us our big data analysis
on a Google cloud platform TCP with a
big query and then you use your kitchen
data and then you prepare their accurate
weight system the kind of thing we are
doing now I'm take charge over this side
that decide yeah as I said I'm in charge
over games of CAI yeah ai related to
game operation or kind of activity now
outside of a game for example marketing
and operation and also a pig on a potato
analysis yes so I make a some simple
strategy and just ABC I want to give a I
want to provide actionable inside to
inside everybody inside the name bubble
you know I don't know many games did you
try to you know predict prediction right
Chum prediction and lt prediction
anything but the kind thing is a
actually meaningful is my question for
many years we try to copy the west up
company you know where some content
looks like a wall you know higher than
our hourly so we try to catch up
everything so we try to predict Chum
we try to predict LTV and our conclusion
is yes you can do that but so what so
what we can do to make more money or
make a better service is another
question
so these day our team focusing on a
making actionable insight deliver
actionable insight to everybody in a
in a inside of name mobile for example
we give us a simple loss prediction
liquid to marketer you can decide
everything based on data and then you
the marketer can I decide you know more
money I will spend over stub you stop
stop spending or you know changing at
marketing channel and every day they
making a try to optimize everything
based on a data that kind of thing I
really want to do that and vision is
impact you know AI a machine learning is
a very very trendy tech and it's a
cancer with many problems but for me
technical solving technical problem
isn't that attractive
we I really want to solve a simple
problem but the idea has a huge business
impact
for example we developed a de prata
t-taking system daresay by huge money
for forms of marketing and the kind of
thing I really want to do that at the
same time the mobile is a mobile game
company that means we don't have a very
good developers strong development power
over AI or machine learning to solve
that problem we really try to
collaboration with the other big company
for example we have a very good
relationship with Google Google cloud
okay so team ESO team throw by the many
insight to us to develop a new problem
and develop new system and there's over
our headache problems they are very
smart and we are catching out their
ability but one more thing is you know
we try to solve right problem you know
right the problem is some something we
really want to solve and that is human
cancer but sometime NIDA a lot of people
and it takes a lot of time the kind of
problem is a perfect perfect for using a
machine learning we believe and we
already tried the several case and
bakers are a good leader so cases for
marketing we do the LTV prediction
lowest prediction and the earth
protection detection systems and you
know as I said we developed a TV
prediction but nobody using there
because you know it's just a little bit
hard to use for mass marketing and the
in Korea
Alton appreciates and that's so
important and that is also same in
Southeast Asia and maybe a Japan so we
developed Lois prediction when we can
lik cook our marketing budget one
syllabus you know we predict your
marketing budget will really cook in a
two months or three months later four
months later and then we developed a
system and you know the free teaching is
a very very high currently is how can I
say maybe approach - 15 days this a Lily
Lily accurate accurate and our posts
always decide to spend more money based
on a loss prediction and also we
developed at the predictor system you
know that is a headache for many
marketer and its really Lily there are
so many solutions for example s flyer
also provide the kind of thing and the
many
taking company provide us some solution
to detect a plot problem is we don't
want to rely on a outside of a company
and we believe we have plenty data to
detecting ed fraud by ourselves and we
tried and making a huge success for Kane
service operation we developed Charlie
put like every every other other guys
but we use the machine learning fine
find out the difference between leaving
or staying you just by you know what
kind of a difference they have yeah you
know somebody living after enjoying
server
you know PvP loss and somebody stay
lumber if they play the five or six time
or they they kind of insight we want to
extract from data and now every morning
our operation team members together take
the report yeah what kind of trend is
going on in a kind of key difference
between a Chargers in staying users and
also we developed our own special charm
friction report you know we focusing on
a key verse of Samson's nikka give some
clue for action for example yeah here's
somebody and the chart there Chung Chung
probably Tavia over ninety percent that
means we can't do anything he will go
out and he will enjoy the other title
and somebody here in the trumpet
translation maybe ever maybe as generate
maybe 60% or 80% but you know our second
day of attention is over 50% so 60,000
is a higher or not it's really really
hard to understand for
or daily operation guys so we just give
us our simple guide ride just focusing
on that each guy and if you can control
you can hold the guy may be a the day of
the plow you can make a carers of a huge
retention improvement they kind of
liquid we deliver every day and now also
we developed in game on the multi
detection and then there is our
collaboration project to be the Google
PSO team you know this day our title
service video it is a long way longer
and longer
that means content is a very very
complex it is really hard to maintain
you know bog free status and theory will
be always booked there is that means
there is always bog orbiter how to find
that a kind of a user as soon as
possible there is a one of a key one of
the most important problem to solve is a
long way and longer and longer so I we
developed a test systems so I want to
keep drive a deep dive three case one is
Alyssa Mara we put do you know Lisa Mara
the one in all right we some are yeah
you're from Japan yes miss Emma is a
very very interesting way to enjoy game
content
Lisa Mara is we said combine marathon
you know in Japan and the in Asia
usually free-to-play game adopting a
culture business model come in sir you
know how can I say oh yeah do you
familiar to capture something like a low
key box right and for you know in Japan
Marketing prices are really really high
that means we want to hold user and list
one or today then me them means we had
to give us a very good impression at the
launching time so we prepare some
special cutter box only for new users it
contains something a very special car
doors very special character or very
special gift to get that user Lisa that
means delete and Ally install app
continuously for maybe a two or three
days without starting usually maybe are
200 times or 300 times user can get a
sum of actual what they want but some
time is over 1000 or 2000 times this
looks like a very stupid but anyway they
try that and they that is also a one of
our main message to enjoy at again in
Japan and in Southeast Asia problem is
can't trust every KPI you know the
tension is very low that is because
overl is Emma don't worry know that and
false a sign of gift is good enough
nobody know that but it's something like
Alyssa my is too high that means we give
a too good gift to assign user but it
will be similar to small number that
means you know it's a not good enough
and how many account the change has
happened that is a also very important
thing you know something like that this
title is a very good and that this title
give us our very special a sign of gift
and then they do ELISA Mara and there's
some in China at this kind of situation
they make listen more palm to get us of
a special account and generating has so
many account and said that to Japan
actual player and the take kind of thing
is came break the balance of the game so
it's very very dangerous thing so we
make a list Merida photo system using a
many Google cloud platform swabbies this
we are not using a machine learning or
some special symbol anyway we can
analyze every user log data in your time
because of Vickery and the powerful
Google cloud platform so finally we can
you know we we can generate a trustful
or KPI without Lisa Mara this is very
important we developed a thing maybe a
last week that is I wish my developers
to prepare key mobile fighter
ulster launching and a default system
you know to explain how ed Pradas is a
headache for me I just searched google
and the find is all very simple article
about their you know mobile ad spending
is growing another 20% this year
and you know 20% I'm gonna do every
title hair cell thought I mean that
illegal download or something like a
clicking palm or something somewhere you
know just to get money without
installing and then just or stealing
install from others the kind of thing is
a heaven or gaining or gaining again you
know this it's maker or not a problem
you know Bob means they will not enjoy
our title and that we spend money and
that they you know the retention will be
going down problem is without at prod
actual retention will be a little bit
more higher that means we have to spend
our money to more bigger success but
because over at the plot we can't decide
something like a life we can't make a
right decision
so we developed at approach detection
system and I will explain how we detect
their first we create code then we
create code specific variable and
calculate normal range of fire every
variable we are maintaining some of
height lift over at the edge channels
some something like a forum for facebook
facebook is really hard to make us and
Janica you know Eddie floss so the kind
of data we are collecting now and
comparing you know untrustful traffic
for you this kind of cohort is a little
bit strange right
everybody looks like at this one but you
know here servers of this one we give us
some of reported to marketer and the
marketer check
deep-dive it and you know find out this
is a something like a board or not yeah
this is diagram funny thing is this day
also a very simple trick to get out
money from us something like a click
palm the kind of thing still exist so we
developed a one more looked just
comparing to standard and others and
also checking out a simple rule for you
them for Justin Logan same time and that
just the local same time just injured
just try to content you at the same time
they kind of was a simple click boat or
we can find with the simple rules and
the last is a in game or normality
texture yes is all all T this is a human
you know lying down in head it's funny
but it's a expression over something
like a angry you know because of some
book or some orbiter was over some some
operation port in Korea user angry about
it and making something like this kind
of article Gupta it's a means a lie down
and that the kind of a thing is a very
very dangerous force because you know it
makes some bear the expression of a pet
bed branding for our title and then to
prevent this kind of thing we have to
find out for visual as soon as possible
so we developed a rule-based engine
the problem is every month we provide a
new content
means everyone's we had to prepare new
rule to detect fog orbiter that is
almost impossible because you know it's
too complex and the nobody care about
the system they just want to focusing on
a developing new content they don't want
to make a new design role so Lu based
engine cannot solve our problems so a VI
was acting a arrest game autoencoder
network to solve this problem and
because it was most effective algorithm
for analyzing the user behavior by
sequence and then filtering the outliner
this compressed active tracer we
developed we use every kind of a TCP
service and then we control the using
our jenkins and yeah
and the we do a sort of a segment
approach that is a digital EDA how do we
managing that we report the abnormality
detected a little - to operation part
every hour and people at the operator
check the game inside the situation and
if there is something like a clock
reporting to developers develop a fixed
step and the we just append the upper
curvature every hours there is a
constituent you know the joint
so summary yeah I don't want to try this
one again yeah the mobile has been
utilizing machine learning one by one
for the area that needs a lot of people
to walk on and that require a light a
lot of time and some problem has a big
vicious effect there are many things to
do in the future but yeah I believe with
a title tight collaboration with the
Google Cloud and PSO team we can solve
many problems as soon as possible we
will try that continuously I believe
yeah next year maybe we can provide more
insightful case to everybody and then
time I think I will hire something like
English speaking English native person
tutors of speech for me instead of me
thank you thank you
and we don't prepare any Q&A but anyway
these three guys are wearing same
t-shirts that means their actual
developer I'm just pushing them to make
this kind of lizard and the day you know
what kind of coated a manger that means
you can ask any any kind of a Christian
forgive them for why you are using a
recipe and that is a really helpful for
not that kind of question you can ask
for them not for me thank you very much
[Music]
you